[Musique]
le château de Versailles est l'un des
plus beaux trésors du monde tout ce que
compte cette immense domaine a été
réalisé par les plus grands artistes de
l'histoire tout ici ou presque est un
trésor nous pouvons aujourd'hui admirer
cette immense domaine unique au monde
grâce à une équipe de conservateurs qui
le maintient dans un état remarquable je
vous propose de les suivre car ils vont
vous faire découvrir un Versailles
différents un Versailles secret ils vont
nous permettre d'aller à la rencontre de
notre histoire ils vont nous faire
pénétrer dans les coulisses de ce
domaine les outils les plus en pointe
comme les plus traditionnels sont
utilisés afin de faire vivre cette
résidence royale et ce musée dans le
seul but de nous présenter les plus
beaux trésors de l'art français je vous
propose maintenant de pousser toutes les
portes du domaine et des découvrir les
trésors du château de Versailles
le domaine royal de Versailles s'étend
aujourd'hui sur plus de 800 hectares il
est composé de trois châteaux de deux
écuries de multiples jardins de parcs et
de nombreuses dépendances et derrière
tout ça il y a 1000 personnes qui
travaillent il y a 7 millions et demi de
visiteurs qui viennent de chaque année
nous allons vous faire découvrir son
évolution au XVIIe siècle grâce à de
formidables reconstitutions en 3D du
XIXe siècle à la Seconde Guerre mondiale
le domaine et la proie des ravages de
l'histoire et du temps ce que découvre
le ministre et choquant il voit qu'on a
mis des gamelles dans la galerie des
glaces pour recueillir la pluie qui
tombe des voûtes il a fallu la volonté
et l'énergie d'hommes et de femmes
passionnées pour redonner toute sa
splendeur à ce trésor classé au
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité
aujourd'hui les équipes du château
s'emploi chaque jour à conserver
restaurer la magnificence de ce lieu et
de ses chefs
tout à fait exceptionnel c'est un
mobilier tout à fait original donc l'une
des très belles pièces du hameau avec
eux nous allons découvrir comment à
Versailles le château est remulé pour
retrouver son apparence de résidence
royale comme dans les appartements des
filles de Louis XV où les petits
cabinets privés de Louis XVI qui nous
ont exceptionnellement ouvert leurs
portes
vous allez découvrir les derniers
chantiers de restauration comme le
hameau de Marie-Antoinette et pénétré
dans les ateliers des artisans d'art qui
redonnent vie à des objets d'exception
vu la bonne surprise de retrouver de
l'or qui a été posé à l'époque de Louis
XV en fait pour la commande royale donc
c'est vraiment très émouvant
ensemble nous allons pénétrer dans des
lieux méconnus et nous glisser dans les
coulisses d'une exposition temporaire
spectaculaire
là on peut donner l'impression de ce que
les comptes temporaires pouvaient
ressentir en face de ça enfin vous allez
découvrir des chefs-d'œuvre insoupçonnés
qui vont faire l'objet d'un grand projet
le musée de l'Histoire de France nous
avons la chance d'avoir cette collection
qui est un vrai trésor c'est-à-dire nous
sommes le seul pays au monde qui
conserve toute son histoire nationale
dans un même lieu
à travers ces trésors
tisons dans le plus beau palais du monde
qui a fait l'histoire de France
[Musique]
aujourd'hui dans les jardins de
Versailles des visiteurs se pressent
autour d'un bassin et sa fontaine afin
d'en admirer les détails et dans
commenter la beauté c'est le bassin de
la tonne qu'ils admirent et pour cause
il vient tout juste d'être entièrement
restaurée
on peut dire du bassin de la tonne que
c'est un des trésors de Versailles c'est
à peu près l'équivalent de la galerie
des glaces dans les jardins du château
de Versailles les jardins de Versailles
sont bâtis sur un axe orienté est-ouest
à l'image de la course du soleil sur cet
axe on trouve le grand canal le bassin
d'Apollon le tapis vert et le majestueux
bassin de la tonne avec ses marbres
polychromes sont riches décors de plomb
pour des jeux d'eau éblouissants
[Musique]
il a fallu réunir sept corps de métiers
d'excellence pour une restauration qui a
duré deux années
quand on a ouvert finalement
ce bassin latin c'est comme si on avait
fait une opération à cœur ouvert on est
allé au cœur de ce bassin et je crois
qu'une de mes émotions les plus fortes
c'est lorsque l'architecte des jardins
m'a dit vous voyez la glaise que vous
voyez là certainement que le nôtre l'a
vu aussi
ce bassin fait partie d'un ensemble
exceptionnel unique au monde le domaine
de Versailles
ce domaine a vu le jour au 17e siècle
grâce à la volonté et l'imagination d'un
seul homme le roi de France
tout commence en 1623 lorsque le roi
Louis XII fait bâtir un pavillon de
chasse remplacer quelques années plus
tard par un tout petit château de
briques et de pierres
à l'automne 1624 le premier Versailles
né
ce qu'il reste de ce château c'est
l'actuel cours de marbre dont le volume
est resté inchangé
le roi Louis XIV accède au trône en 1643
il a 5 ans très attaché au château de
son père il décide une fois adulte de
grands travaux et fait construire deux
nouveaux bâtiments de part et d'autre de
la cour c'est à ce moment-là que va
naître un décor mythique aujourd'hui
disparu
la grotte de Thétis était une grotte
artificielle
l'effet de surprise provoquée par le
contraste entre la simplicité du décor
extérieur et la profusion baroque de
l'Intérieur
enfile l'une des réalisations les plus
extravagantes du jeune roi
[Musique]
pour se rendre compte de l'atmosphère
qui pouvait tirer il faut aller dans le
Val de Loire voir la grotte de la
Bastille d'Urfé elle a été conçue
quelques années plus tôt et offre un
aperçu saisissant de ce que pouvait être
ses décors féeriques
la grotte de tétise est une sorte de
lodia qui ouvre sur les jardins par
trois arcades et qui a atteint un lieu
de divertissement puisqu'il y a des
effets d'eau des jeux d'eau avec de
l'eau qui sort du sol qui goûte des
lustres
[Musique]
c'est dans les entrailles et du château
de Versailles que l'on peut retrouver le
plus bel ensemble statuaire qui traînait
dans la grande salle de la grotte
voici les derniers vestiges de la grotte
de tétis 3 magnifiques sculptures en
marbre Apollon servi par les nymphes les
groupes des chevaux du soleil les chefs
de Versailles la Joconde de Versailles
aujourd'hui conservée en réserve puisque
la grotte malheureusement a été détruite
[Musique]
à partir de 1668 l'architecte Louis
Leveaux enveloppe le château de Louis
XIII et réalise deux grands appartements
en symétrie pour le roi et la reine
[Musique]
le grand appartement du roi une
majestueuse enfilade de 7 salons sera
dotée des décors les plus somptueux ces
salons d'apparat deviennent le cadre des
actes officiels du souverain
[Musique]
mais il ne se contente pas de rendre les
intérieurs majestueux il va apporter le
même raffinement dans les jardins ici
n'existait que des bois des prairies et
des marécages
[Musique]
à partir de 1679
Mansart a grandi de nouveau le château
avec l'aile du midi pour loger les
princes il réalise une grande et une
petite écurie et les ailes des ministres
pour tous les services administratifs du
gouvernement
[Musique]
trois ans plus tard le Roi fixe sa cour
et le gouvernement à Versailles dès lors
ce château sera l'assise de sa politique
intérieure et extérieure
mais Louis XIV va demander à son
architecte jullardeau Mansart de fermer
la terrasse sur le parc pour créer une
grande galerie appelée aujourd'hui
galerie des Glaces elle deviendra le
grand espace de réception et d'apparat
de la cour
Versailles est alors un véritable outil
politique pour Louis XIV une façon
sublime de montrer sa puissance
[Musique]
en 1687 le Roi Soleil demande à Mansart
de construire un petit château où il
peut se retirer un peu pour plus
d'intimité ce sera chose faite dans le
parc du domaine avec le Grand Trianon
Louis XIV dira j'ai fait Versailles pour
ma cour Marly pour mes amis et Trianon
pour moi
il manquait au château une chapelle
digne du projet du souverain
1689 un chantier lancé par Jules Ardouin
Mansart dédié à Saint-Louis ancêtre et
saint patron de la famille royale cette
chapelle est le dernier édifice
construit à Versailles sous le règne de
Louis XIV
les équipes du château ont retrouvé un
objet symbolique prouesse de l'artisanat
d'art français une clé que l'on a
exceptionnellement ressorti de sa
vitrine
c'est un objet tout à fait royal avec le
la couronne royale qui la domine le
chiffre c'est-à-dire les initiales de
Louis XIV le double l entre la C et un
très beau Pen marqué une fleur de lys
mais ajourée
[Musique]
c'est vraiment la clé la chapelle parce
que donc son elle s'adapte parfaitement
à l'entrée de serrures et puis on
retrouve le même décor avec cette
couronne royale ici qui somme l'entrée
de serrure et ici qui est au sommet de
la clé
ce fabuleux objet en bronze doré avait
disparu à la Révolution française il est
revenu au château grâce à un don par
l'intermédiaire de la Société des Amis
de Versailles
[Musique]
c'est une fille qu'on a dû remettre au
roi le jour de l'inauguration de la
chapelle parce que c'est un très bel
objet et évidemment qui vient
concrétiser l'inauguration de
l'achèvement de l'édifice 300 ans après
elle revient à son lieu d'origine et
c'est donc un événement extrêmement
émouvant
la chapelle royale est l'un des grands
chefs-d'œuvre de l'arsacré pas moins de
deux architectes 8 peintres et 110
sculpteurs furent mobilisés pour
concevoir et réaliser le dernier grand
chantier de Louis XIV
un projet dans lequel le roi fut
particulièrement investi
Louis XIV ne connut sa chapelle que les
cinq dernières années de sa vie
[Musique]
dans cette dernière partie de Rennes le
roi des place sa chambre au centre du
château cette chambre rythme les
cérémonies de la journée et la vie de
tous les courtisans de Versailles
c'est ici que Louis XIV s'étend le 1er
septembre 1715
[Musique]
lorsque son arrière petit-fils le roi
Louis XV s'installe à Versailles il va
subir l'étiquette stricte mise en place
par Louis XIV d'un tempérament solitaire
est plus sombre il va rechercher plus
d'intimité et faire aménager de petits
appartements derrière le grand
appartement de parade
[Musique]
cet espace fonctionne comme un hôtel
particulier dans lequel Louis XV va
vivre quotidiennement et il faut savoir
que il y a des courtisans qui ont habité
Versailles pendant des dizaines d'années
et qui n'ont jamais vu cet espace alors
que nous sommes à 5 mètres des espaces
les plus publics du château on entre
dans ces appartements intérieurs par des
portes dérobées juste à côté de la
bouillonnante galerie des glaces et
progressivement on glisse des
appartements les plus officiels au plus
intimes
[Musique]
ces appartements font le tour d'une cour
intérieure la cour des serres
Louis XVI organise de petits souper pour
la première fois dans l'histoire le roi
Dinan petit comité et c'est un véritable
privilège d'être convié à ses repas
intimes
était assis chose complètement
inconcevable à l'époque de être assis en
présence du roi chacun se servait en
prenant la bouteille de vin les plats et
donc une véritable convivialité dans un
espace réduit du château
d'abondance au miel de nouvelles France
voilà qui nous plaît accompagné d'une
crème de cardon en caisse et d'une purée
de jus au monde
un miracle mes amis manger de bon
appétit
[Musique]
à la fin de son règne il fait construire
ce qu'il manquait au château l'Opéra
royal
dans cette salle de spectacle il va
aussi montrer son goût de la discrétion
[Musique]
cette Opéra royal possède une loge
fermée ou le roi pouvait assister au
spectacle presque incognito accompagné
de ses proches et de ses ministres
plus grande salle de spectacles d'Europe
au moment de son inauguration en 1770
l'Opéra royal est paru du plus grand
raffinement décoratif
pour sa favorite la belle marquise de
Pompadour Louis XV demande à son premier
architecte de construire un pavillon
d'un genre nouveau le Petit Trianon
Jacques Ange Gabriel va imaginer un
écrin néoclassique un édifice de plan
carré simple et épuré
les décorations antérieures sont du
dernier affinement comme les boiseries
qui rendent hommage à la nature et à
l'atmosphère champêtre
Louis XV c'est un temps 1774 laissant le
royaume à son petit-fils Louis XVI qui
offre le domaine du Petit Trianon à
Marie-Antoinette
elle y crée un univers personnel et
intime loin des fastes de la cour
un trésor reflète à merveille cette
époque
c'est le portrait de Marie-Antoinette
par le peintre Elisabeth Viger Lebrun le
plus connu au monde de la reine on y
retrouve je dirais tout le talent de
l'artiste cette grande élégance cette
grâce mais également je dirais cette
poésie qui est le propre de cette
peinture et surtout l'expression du
sentiment c'est un peintre qui éprouve
beaucoup d'empathie qui nous donne une
image de la reine idéalisée
mais ressemblante et je dirais que la
reine est sublimée sous le pinceau de
l'artiste
si la reine se sont bien au Petit
Trianon le roi aime son château dont il
ne modifie pas la structure avec
Marie-Antoinette il renouvelle la
décoration de leurs appartements comme
la chambre de parade de la reine
il fait également quelques modifications
dans ces petits appartements ou les
souverains vont rechercher encore plus
d'intimité comme dans le salon des jeux
ici en fait on jouait alors on jouait au
Tric Trac on jouait au brelan on jouait
au tri ont joué au quadrilles donc vous
aviez pour ce faire un certain nombre de
tables pour les besoins du jeu
c'est ici que le roi se réunit après le
souper avec quelques convives triés sur
le volet le roi adorait jouer au Tric
Trac l'ancêtre du backgammon
[Musique]
chose rare la plupart des meubles du
salon des jeux sont ceux qu'a connus
Louis XVI
[Musique]
25 chaises sur les 36 qui est un cas
tout à fait exceptionnel les quatre
inconnus de rissner et on sait combien
les bénistes étaient courus et quelle
importance il avait et vous remarquerez
le travail admirable de marqueterie en
mosaïque enrichie de bronze doré de très
grande qualité
de leur côté les petits appartements de
la reine vont connaître avec
Marie-Antoinette des décors remarquables
le cabinet doré est un chef-d'oeuvre
absolu c'est la pièce au monde où l'on
compte le plus de meubles et d'objets
d'art ayant véritablement appartenu à la
reine
c'est une des pièces les plus intimes du
château de Versailles
habituellement elle n'est visible qu'à
travers une vitre de protection
[Musique]
pour échapper à la pression de la cour
la reine demande aussi à son architecte
de lui édifier un petit village normand
dans le parc du Petit Trianon ce sera le
hameau elle est à la pointe de la mode
et la tendance est à la nature à
l'atmosphère champêtre
[Musique]
mais les souverains disparaissent trop
souvent dans leurs espaces intimes il ne
voit pas ce profiler le mécontentement
et les événements qui s'approchent
à Paris la fin et les mouvements
politiques engendrent des émeuts le 5
octobre 6000 femmes vont marcher sur
Versailles
cinq d'entre elles rencontreront le roi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis bien naissent de vous voir chez
moi
que puis-je pour vous
[Musique]
aurez du pain
promener
le roi promet du pain mais les émeutiers
ne partent pas pour autant
chose incroyable la famille royale va se
coucher et en bas le peuple campe
pendant quelques heures
nous sommes le 6 octobre il est 5h30 du
matin
[Musique]
après un incident dans la cour de Marbre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est l'étincelle et alors là on bascule
dans quelque chose de complètement fou
la foule en furie se précipite à
l'intérieur du château sans réfléchir
les émeutiers se dirigent d'abord vers
la porte la plus proche celle située à
droite en haut de l'escalier elle ouvre
sur la salle des gardes de la reine
Marie-Antoinette se trouve dans ses
appartements gardés par ces seules
femmes de chambre qui sont pressent de
verrouiller les portes
les femmes de chambre entendent un garde
du corps qui crie sauver la reine et la
reine n'est poussée par ses femmes par
le passage secret qui la relie à
l'appartement du roi
Antoinette est quand même assez agité à
la qu'une idée c'est de se retrouver
auprès de ses enfants et auprès du roi
et elle sait que ce passage là
traditionnellement est toujours ouvert
arrivé à la porte de l'oeil de bœuf la
porte est fermée à clé
Marie-Antoinette effrayait tambourine à
la porte mais on lui ouvrira qu'au bout
de cinq longues minutes
[Musique]
alors même qu'elle se précipitait ainsi
vers la chambre du roi Louis XVI de son
côté s'est rendu chez sa femme par un
passage privé situé à l'entre-sol
[Musique]
en sortant de ce passage Louis XVI se
rend directement dans la chambre de la
reine qui se trouve juste derrière les
femmes de chambre le rassurent la reine
et sa naissance donc le roi n'a plus
qu'à reprendre cette fois-ci ce passage
là se retrouver dans l'oeil de bœuf et
retrouver l'ensemble de la famille
royale qui l'attend
c'est la première fois que
grande masse de population comme ça fait
plier le pouvoir en son cœur et c'est
pas la prise de la Bastille ça c'est
vraiment la population qui fait plier le
pouvoir donc c'est beaucoup plus
important que la prise de la Bastille en
quelque sorte
quelques heures plus tard sous un
radieux soleil d'automne la famille
royale monte en carrosse et kit
Versailles
le roi prisonnier des événements voient
disparaître au loin le château qu'il a
vu naître jamais plus aucun souverain
n'habitera le château de Versailles
[Musique]
menacée de destruction le domaine est
finalement préservé sous le Premier
Empire Napoléon ne s'installe pas au
château mais fait réaménager le Grand
Trianon il souhaite y séjourner à la
belle saison avec sa nouvelle épouse
Marie-Louise je me trouve ici dans
l'appartement de l'impératrice à
grandriano dans son salon des glaces ce
salon est le plus beau de l'elsud il a
conservé son décor Louis XIV et a été
entièrement remulé par Napoléon une
grande partie du mobilier présent ici
sont les meubles d'origine nous avons
dans ce salon un ensemble exceptionnel
des frères Jacob des Malters qui ont
créé le style Empire et signé de
nombreux trésors du mobilier français
les rideaux sont en l'empasse de soie
d'origine dit des quatre parties du
monde et tissées à Lyon
au Premier Empire succède la
restauration en 1832 le roi
Louis-Philippe transforme l'ancienne
résidence royale en un musée de
l'Histoire de France les anciens
appartements des princes de l'aile du
Midi sont remplacés par une grande
galerie de peinture la galerie des
Batailles
quelques années plus tard en 1875 la
Troisième République fait aménager la
salle du Congrès qui peut accueillir
l'Assemblée et le Sénat
tous ces événements et ses
bouleversements ont mal mené le château
qui n'est plus la splendeur qu'il a été
mais c'était sans compter sur quelques
passionnés
aujourd'hui Versailles a retrouvé la
splendeur d'antan les remous du XIXe
siècle n'ont pourtant pas épargné le
château
[Musique]
on peut dire que dans les années
189890 il reste quand même plus grand
chose des beaux décors tout ça est dans
un état d'abandon dans un état de
désordre de poussière aussi il faut le
dire terrible nous sommes en 1897 un
historien nommé Pierre de nolaque
devient conservateur du Musée de
Versailles petit à petit il se prend de
passion il se prend d'amour pour les
lieux et lui avec la rigueur de
l'historien il va revenir aux sources il
va sortir les archives les plans etc il
réécrit l'histoire de cette maison dès
son arrivée pierre de Nola que veut
mettre en place une organisation
scientifique pour atteindre son but il
réaménage des salles décroche des œuvres
remet à jour certains décors historiques
il crée la première politique de
conservation est fait de Versailles le
lieu de promenade préféré des Parisiens
[Musique]
mais la Première Guerre mondiale vient
tuer dans l’œuf ce regain de vie au
château de Versailles bien qu’éloigné de
la ligne de front le domaine est
délaissé et qu'en pierre de nos lac le
quitte en 1919 les bassins sont éventrés
les canalisations crevées les murs
fissurés les toitures percées
Atlantique en mai 1924 qu'une solution
vient se profiler John Davidson
Rockefeller junior le fils du célèbre
milliardaire qui a fait la guerre en
France et en admire le patrimoine décide
de lui venir en aide les dotations des
Rockefeller vont être une sorte de
miracle pour Versailles parce que là on
peut se mettre vraiment à restaurer les
bâtiments à reprendre les jardins
[Musique]
et bien entendu pour l'État français
c'est un petit peu là honte quand même
donc les députés comme par miracle se
mettent à voter des fonds ce qui veut
dire que d'un seul coup c'est une pluie
d'argent qui serait pendant sur
Versailles officiellement par Monsieur
Jean et ministre de l'éducation
nationale Monsieur et Madame Rockefeller
visite la demeure royale mais cette
parenthèse enchantée est de courte durée
la Seconde Guerre mondiale éclate
Versailles subit de nombreuses
dégradations
en 1951 le conservateur en chef du
château alerte le ministre des
Beaux-Arts André Cornu sur l'état de
délabrement de Versailles et ce que
découvre le ministre et choquant il voit
qu'on a mis des gamelles dans la galerie
des glaces pour recueillir la pluie qui
tombe des voûtes c'est épouvantable donc
il est grand temps de faire quelque
chose
le ministre c'est que les subventions de
l'État ne suffiront pas alors en homme
de communication et sollicite à la radio
l'aide des Français nous avons retrouvé
son intervention radiophonique qui a été
un tournant dans l'histoire du château
vous dire que Versailles menace ruine
c'est vous dire que ce n'est pas
seulement un chef-d'oeuvre de l'art
qu'on peut craindre de voir disparaître
mais en chacun de nous Français une
image de la France qu'aucune autre ne
serait remplacé
j'ai calculé que si chacun y affectait
l'argent d'un paquet de Gauloises les 5
milliards seraient trouvés et l'on voit
les français partout mettre la main à la
poche les Français fortunés qui font de
gros chèques mais également on a vu
arriver à Versailles des tout petits
chèques de 5 francs mais peu importe si
tout le monde sait mis ensemble c'est
que Versailles est dans l'inconscient
collectif une sorte de trésor suprême
[Musique]
mais en avril 1953 le conservateur du
château des 7 brutalement André Cornu
doit nommer son remplaçant celui qu'il
choisit ne fait pas l'unanimité il
s'appelle Gérald vandercamp n'est pas
spécialiste de Versailles et a à peine
30 ans dans les milieux autorisés c'est
l'effroi qui est ce Vandercam peut bien
chez l'homme qui quand même à Valençay
protégeait les réserves du Louvre
pendant l'Occupation il a été mis en
jour il a été mis au peloton d'exécution
pour révéler l'endroit où se trouvait un
certain nombre de trésors et la refusé
de parler aux Allemands qui ne l'ont pas
tué et il est une sorte de héros de
guerre si vous voulez c'est la raison
peut-être pour laquelle
Cornu le Nord
Gérald vandercampe nourri pour
Versailles une véritable ambition la
grande idée l'idée géniale de Gérald
vanderchem c'est de remettre du mobilier
avec
toutes ces grandes pièces toutes vides
il veut les remeubler mais ça c'est pas
une mince affaire
en effet la tâche est grande le château
est vide tout le mobilier d'anciens
régimes a été dispersé à la Révolution
et se trouve disséminé à l'étranger et
éparpillés dans les musées ou les
institutions d'État mais Gérald
vandercampe ne se laisse pas décourager
et va donner son élan à la politique de
remublement au château il fait revenir
les oeuvres mais sortent parfois des
refus ainsi le musée du Louvre résiste à
se séparer de ce qui fut l'un des plus
beaux trésors de Versailles le bureau à
cylindre de Louis XV
chef-d'œuvre parmi les chefs il a été
réalisé par rizner le plus grand
ébéniste de son temps
enfin politique
vandercamp profite de la réception
d'Elisabeth II en 1957 pour réclamer le
bureau provisoirement la demande est
officielle le Louvre s'incline
sauf qu'une fois que le secrétaire a été
là il n'a plus été question du tout de
le voir repartir et vanderchem a dit
pour que le secrétaire s'en aille il
faudra me passer sur le corps moi vivant
il restera Versailles et à l'heure où
nous parlons il y est toujours
[Musique]
œuvre d'art n'a pas livré tous ces
secrets et aujourd'hui trois siècles
après sa création les équipes de la
conservation se penchent encore sur ces
mystères il aurait été tant de multiples
couleurs
elles sont verdâtres
et quand vous êtes en face enlevez votre
lampe on est dans les dans les rouges ou
dans les jaunes au lieu de voir un
meuble avec un bois avec des tonalités
majoritairement dans les marrons vous
imaginez un bois avec du blanc du rouge
du vert du violet du mauve et toutes les
couleurs de l'univers
afin de percer ce mystère une
collaboration avec le laboratoire des
musées de France est mené et les
dernières avancées technologiques
utilisées
et deux photographies complémentaires
ont été faites l'une sous infrarouge et
l'autre sous ultraviolet
l'infrarouge révèle d'éventuels
inscriptions comme la signature de
l'église
[Musique]
l'ultraviolet permet de percevoir les
anciens pigments
[Musique]
là vous avez une vue d'ensemble en
ultraviolet et on voit très bien que les
fleurs que vous avez ici qui sont en
poirier étaient des fleurs rouges donc
aujourd'hui elles sont oranges et là ça
prouve que c'est des fleurs étaient
rouges à l'origine
sur le verre tu étais gris gris argent
on retrouve régulièrement sur les
meubles de cette ébéniste là et toutes
les branches le feuillage et les fleurs
aller justement du bleu au vert le
branches étaient vertes le ruban devait
probablement bleu et des fleurs devaient
être jaunes
mais revenons aux années 60 Gérald
vandercamp ne se contente pas de faire
revenir ce magnifique bureau de Louis XV
Béatrix saule aujourd'hui directrice
générale du château a travaillé sous sa
direction et se souvient Gérald van
derkamp a eu l'audace de faire des
restitutions complètes dans la chambre
du roi et dans la chambre de la reine
alors voilà quelque chose que je vous
présente qui est tout à fait inédit
c'est la maquette faite par nos ateliers
à grandeurs et suivant les inventaires
du lit de la chambre du roi c'est très
exceptionnel que je vous le montre
personne ne l'a encore vu il nous faut
une beaucoup de placement de prix pour
faire cela puisque simplement pour la
passementerie il nous faut 40 kg
d'orphelins
le fait de
oser refaire à l'identique la tenture de
la chambre du roi et tout le liseron en
brocard il a mis 20 ans pour le faire
fil d'or c'était extraordinaire d'audace
puis il remet en état le Grand Trianon
qui va dès lors servir sous la Cinquième
République de résidence pour les chefs
d'État étrangers lors des visites
officielles
Gérald vandercammp donne un nouveau
souffle au château de Versailles un
souffle qui va poser les bases d'une
politique moderne de conservation
en 27 ans celui que l'on appelait VDK a
transformé un monument menacé en une
rutilante vitrine des Arts Décoratifs
français
[Musique]
les équipes de la conservation ont
aujourd'hui plusieurs défis à relever la
sauvegarde des décors
hérité des rois la conservation et la
gestion des collections ainsi que le
remoblement d'un palais autrefois
résidence royale ce rebeublement nous
permet de comprendre comment on vivait à
Versailles au 17e et au 18e siècle je me
trouve ici dans le salon de mercure qui
fait partie du grand appartement du roi
Louis XIV on avait fait sa chambre de
parade c'est-à-dire un lieu public
destiné à la représentation et à la
réception de visiteurs les peintures du
plafond au centre duquel figure mercure
sur son char tiré par deux coqs ont fait
l'objet d'une restauration visant à
retrouver la touche originale de leur
hauteur cette restauration a été suivie
d'un remublement conduit dans le souci
de rétablir aussi exactement que
possible le mobilier d'étiquettes
dispersé à la Révolution
arrêtons-nous un instant sur un de ces
trésors la pendule à automate réalisée
par Antoine Morand en 1706 à Versailles
pour Louis XIV le cadran en bronze
Sisley représente le temps avec sa faux
pour les heures l'aigle et le coq agite
leurs ailes deux amours frappent les
timbres de Denain
puis les portes centrales s'ouvrent et
le roi apparaît sur un piédestal
l'ouverture des nuages laisse voir la
renommer tenant une couronne au-dessus
de la tête du roi
on entend un carillon puis tout
disparaît et leur seul
si le meublement du salon de mercure est
achevé vous allez voir que dans
l'appartement des filles de Louis XV de
nouveau trésors exceptionnels sont en
train de prendre place dans cet
appartement princier dont le rendu est
spectaculaire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui est une journée particulière
à Versailles le château vient d'acquérir
un trésor de la deuxième moitié du
XVIIIe siècle une commode ayant
appartenu à Madame Adélaïde l'une des
filles de Louis XV nous avons eu le
privilège de la découvrir alors qu'elle
vient tout juste d'être restauré et que
les équipes vont procéder à sa mise en
place dans la chambre à coucher de
Madame Adélaïde au rez-de-chaussée du
château
[Musique]
une opération pour le moins délicate
réalisée sous la surveillance de la
conservatrice
ça fait partie du rôle des conservateurs
effectivement d'être présent au moment
des mouvements des œuvres afin de
s'assurer que toutes les conditions
soient garanties pour se transport il y
a une intention une vigilance à observer
voilà alors peut-être est-ce que
effectivement visage est plus sérieux
[Musique]
des spécialistes du transport d'oeuvre
d'art sont mobilisés pour déplacer cette
oeuvre remarquable de Gilles Joubert un
des ébénistes officiel de Louis XV le
marbre le travail de marqueterie et les
bronzes qui font le décor de la commode
demande une technique d'emballage
particulière une première enveloppe
chimiquement neutre une seconde qui
réduit les vibrations et enfin celles
qui protège l'oeuvre contre les chocs
[Musique]
c'est un meuble rare donc les meubles
ayant appartenu à mesdames sont
relativement rares et en plus l'intérêt
de cette commode était également dans
son décor de face de la façade parce que
généralement très souvent vous avez
plutôt en façade une représentation d'un
bouquet de fleurs et là c'est assez rare
d'avoir ce décor d'architecture
ce mobilier d'art a retrouvé une place
digne de sa qualité
les conservateurs travaillent à faire
revivre les appartements des filles de
Louis XV Madame Victoire et Madame
Adélaïde et ont vécu de 1769 jusqu'à la
Révolution
ces pièces ont désormais retrouvé le
Fast et leur fonction d'origine
[Musique]
l'idée de fondatrice demeublement c'est
de faire en sorte que le public
comprenne
comment fonctionnait Versailles ça c'est
rendre intelligible faire sentir qu'elle
était l'atmosphère de la pièce
pour remodeler une pièce l'idéal est de
retrouver le mobilier original mais si
la disparu ou s'il est hors d'atteinte
on reporte son choix sur ce que l'on
appelle une équivalence
[Musique]
on entend par équivalence un meuble qui
ne proviendra pas de Versailles mais
d'une autre maison royale mais qui était
qui avait été livré pour la même
personne ou une personne de rang
équivalent peu à peu
les appartements retrouvent leur meubles
et leurs objets d'art qui en était la
parure
[Musique]
ont pas présenté au public comme dans un
musée et sont mis en scène et on
travaille jusqu'à l'éclairage pour
donner une atmosphère de vie au décor
alors nous sommes dans le grand cabinet
de Madame de l'Aïd c'était son grand
salon de réception où elle recevait son
cercle où elle recevait éventuellement
la famille royale et ici l'une des idées
directrices était de rassembler de ce
qui appartenu à mesdames à Versailles
lorsqu'on pouvait retrouver ses meubles
mais également dans leur résidence
privée favorite le château de Bellevue
de belles vues étaient la résidence
de Mesdames ce sont les meubles de cette
maison ou d'autres maisons royales qui
remplacent de Versailles
ainsi la bibliothèque de Madame Victoire
a retrouvé son atmosphère grâce à ce
principe d'équivalence
à défaut d'avoir retrouvé les bons
sièges on a placé ici un très bel
ensemble qui provient du château de
Choisy de l'ameublement fait pour la
dauphine Marie-Antoinette lorsqu'elle
était arrivée en France en 1770 et c'est
à mobilier qui est exactement
contemporain des meubles qui avaient été
livrés pour les appartements de Mesdames
en 1769 lorsqu'elle s'installe
définitivement dans ses dans ses pièces
connaître les meubles et leur
emplacement les équipes du château font
un long travail de recherche
re meubles ça veut dire d'abord
collationner toutes les informations que
l'on peut avoir sur ce qui était dans
une pièce une fois que l'on sait ce
qu'il pouvait y avoir on va aussi
regarder l'état réel des connexions car
nous avons des collections avec des
meubles remarquables
et pour reconnaître ce qui était
véritablement dans les appartements de
mesdames les conservateurs se réfèrent à
un document Le Journal du Garde-Meuble
de la couronne dans lequel chaque meuble
ou chaque objet est référencé avec un
numéro dès sa livraison au château
[Musique]
notre plus grand plaisir c'est lorsque
l'on remet
une pièce que l'on vient d'acquérir à
l'endroit où il se trouvait parce qu'il
y a une sorte de magie la correspondance
parfaite c'est ce qu'on appelle le bon
meuble à la bonne place
[Musique]
mais les bons meubles ne se trouvent
pas dans les collections du château la
mission des conservateurs est de
chercher à les acquérir
la magie a opéré lorsqu’ils ont fait
revenir au château l'un des plus belles
ensemble décoratifs des filles de Louis
XV une garniture de 5 vases qui a
retrouvé sa place sur la cheminée de
Madame Victoire après un long très long
périple
le vin centrale et les vins assez sont
aux extrémités de la cheminée sont
mentionnés en Angleterre en cours du 19e
siècle puis ils arrivent aux États-Unis
au début du 20e siècle et nous avons pu
les acquérir auprès d'un marchand
new-yorkais en 2012 grâce au mécénat du
groupe LVMH le château de Versailles a
acquis trois de ses vases que Madame
Victoire avait acheté à la Manufacture
Royale de Sèvres
cette garniture a été reconnue oeuvre
d'intérêt patrimonial majeur
ils sont extrêmement rares du fait de
leur couleur de leur décor d'après le
peintre boucher et de leur forme très
originale
si on a les vases à feuilles de laurier
dont on connaît aujourd'hui moins de 10
exemplaires dans le monde donc c'est une
forme tout à fait exceptionnelle très
très sophistiquée l'ensemble de la
garniture a coûté près de 3000 livres à
Madame Victoire c'est une somme très
importante
c'est tout à fait exceptionnel d'avoir
pu réunir cette garniture à l'endroit
même où elle était en 1772 il s'agit du
seul ensemble complet de 5 vases au
monde la magie a pu s'opérer grâce à une
collaboration internationale
pour la première fois dans l'histoire du
château le Métropolitan Museum de New
York a accepté de mettre en dépôt les
deux autres vases qui étaient dans leur
collection
cette collaboration existe aussi avec
d'autres institutions comme le Louvre ou
le Mobilier national
il arrive aussi quelques fois que les
conservateurs et la chance qu'un amateur
d'art privé phase don à Versailles d'une
pièce de ses collections le don le plus
récent c'est cette très belle commode
c'était énorme commode en lac du Japon
et bronze doré qui a été livré pour la
chambre de Louis XV au château de Choisy
que Louis XV meublé à grand frais en
cette commode acquise grâce au don de
Madame Lily Safra et de provenance
royale et d'une très grande valeur car à
l'inverse d'autres commodes dont
l'ornementation était fabriquée en série
le dessin des bronzes est un modèle
unique créé pour mettre en valeur des
feuilles de lac du Japon des collections
de Louis XIV si le remublement permet la
présentation de tous ces trésors il va
encore plus loin nous sommes efforcés
dans cet appartement de Mesdames de
replacer des portraits des personnages
qui ont pu fréquenter ces lieux de façon
à incarner aussi les lieux on a aussi
envie de montrer des chefs de Nattier
des chefs de Drouet tous les grands
portraitistes du 18e siècle qui sont là
à la leur plus haut niveau puisqu'il
travaillait pour le roi
ces tableaux nous révèlent que mesdames
étaient de grandes musiciennes plusieurs
instruments témoignent de leur talent
et c'est d'ailleurs dans l'appartement
de Madame Victoire qu'en 1763 Mozart
alors âgé de 7 ans jouait du clavecin
devant la famille royale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un jeune enfant mais un jeune
prodige et qui était plein
d'enthousiasme et sa première réaction a
été lorsqu'il a rencontré Madame de
Pompadour il était impressionné par
cette dame de l'embrasser madame a
refusé son baiser et ça l'a beaucoup
vexé heureusement lorsqu'il a rencontré
Madame Victoire là le succès a été total
et il a été embrassé par ses dames et
couvert de cadeaux et c'est à la suite
de cette visite que Mozart a dédié deux
de ses sonates pour violoncelle la
Madame Victoire laissé vraiment sur ce
type d'instruments que Mozart a joué
lorsqu'il est venu à Versailles un
instrument assez simple mais de grande
qualité
les appartements de Mesdames sont
maintenant ouverts à la visite et le
travail de remublement continue dans
d'autres endroits du château
[Musique]
ainsi juste au-dessus des appartements
privés de Louis XVI on trouve de petites
pièces conservées telles qu'elles
étaient en 1789 sans boiserie nidorure
nous sommes ici dans le jardin secret du
roi Louis XVI passionné par les sciences
il avait installé sous les toits 10
laboratoires et ateliers dont un cabinet
de chimie une galerie de physique où il
se livrait à des expériences
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les murs sont nus mais à
l'époque Louis XVI avait fait accrocher
un très grand nombre de gravures plus de
360 disposés du sol au plafond
dans ces cabinets on a à la fois des
dessins techniques mais aussi des
illustrations d'événements familiaux ce
qui l'intéressait intimement c'est le
roi comme homme privé avec ses intérêts
personnels
[Musique]
pour retrouver la trace de cette
intimité nous avons été autorisés à
pénétrer dans le cabinet des arts
graphiques du château de Versailles
cette réserve possède une collection de
plus de 35
000 dessins et gravures et recèle de
pièces rares dont certains figuraient
dans les petits cabinets de Louis XVI
comme une gravure de Jean-Michel Moreau
qui a été réalisé à l'occasion des fêtes
données pour la naissance du Dauphin le
bal masqué
on a tout à fait au premier plan
différents personnages masqués ou
déguisés au second plan un grand décor
d'architecture qui donne la mesure de
l'événement et puis au centre comme le
fait souvent Moreau presque un peu perdu
dans la foule et on a le roi et la reine
ce qui est souvent très troublant c'est
le luxe détail c'est assez étonnant à
partir de simplement d'une plaque gravée
et d'encre de réussir à donner toute
cette profondeur toute cette vie toute
cette lumière
pour valoriser ces gravures d'exception
les équipes du château vont les replacer
à l'endroit même où elles se trouvait
durant le règne de Louis XVI le roi
aimait avoir sous les yeux les moments
marquants de son règne et de sa vie
familiale
les places tous les trois
c'est ici qu'il était tranquille au
calme dans la sérénité pour
les activités qui l'intéressaient comme
la géographie son pour les voyages pour
les nouveautés techniques de son époque
mais l'accrochage des gravures n'est pas
si simple et donne aux équipes du fil à
retordre
[Musique]
avec le cadre là-haut il faut baisser de
5 mm encore
le but recherché est aussi de mettre en
valeur ces gravures du XVIIIe siècle
je suis très contente de l'accrochage
parce qu'on a l'impression que ça a
toujours été là parce que d'un seul coup
on se dit comment ça pouvait être
autrement avant
faire revivre le château de Versailles
lui redonner l'image d'un palais habité
est un travail de longue haleine et en
perpétuelle évolution à la recherche de
la perfection
car remodeler les quelques 180
000 m² de ce château nécessite de la
recherche de la méthode et surtout une
vision
ainsi les grands appartements sont
redevenus les crins des plus belles
productions du siècle de Louis XIV
les petits appartements des rois Louis
XV et Louis XVI celui d'un art français
à son apogée et au service des
techniques les plus en pointes
Louis XV s'intéressait beaucoup possible
et en particulier à l'astronomie une
extraordinaire pendule lui fut présentée
en 1749
[Musique]
c'est une merveille de sciences c'est le
résumé de tout le savoir astronomique du
temps
la pendule qui a demandé 20 années de
calcul à l'ingénieur du roi Claude
passement est un monument artistique et
scientifique pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'horlogerie tous les
mécanismes sont reliés par un seul arbre
qui marque l'infiniment petit en
scandant les secondes avec le balancier
et l'infiniment grand avec la rotation
des planètes autour du soleil
Louis xvait énormément cette pendule et
d'ailleurs tous les 31 décembre il
venait la regarder pour voir le passage
à l'année d'après c'est une œuvre d'art
qui est la rencontre d'une prouesse
technologique avec la plus grande
qualité artistique c'est une constante
chez nous de vouloir allier les
connaissances scientifiques les plus
pointues avec les découvertes
technologiques les plus récentes les
plus innovantes et que ce soit beau
si le remeublement nous permet d'évoquer
la vie de cours de mettre en valeur des
chefs il arrive parfois que certains
d'entre eux aient subis les avaries du
temps et qu'il faille les restaurer à
Versailles il existe plusieurs ateliers
de restauration qui rassemblent les plus
grands artisans d'art qui exercent et
transmettent leur savoir nous sommes
maintenant dans la grande écurie du
château je suis plus précisément dans la
galerie des carrosses qui est
actuellement fermée au public cet espace
dédié aux voitures historiques va être
complètement réaménagé et rouvrira ses
portes au printemps prochain cette
collection spectaculaire est l'une des
plus belles au monde elle rassemble des
voitures d'apparat qui ont toutes servi
pour leur souverain parmi cette
collection on compte notamment les
berlines du mariage de Napoléon 1er ou
le char funèbre de Louis XV II
l'une des plus belles pièces est sans
doute le carrosse du sacre de Charles X
qui a récemment été restauré ce carrosse
monumental l'un des plus grands au monde
et entièrement décoré de bronze dorées
cellier carrossier menuisier sculpteur
bronzier peintre d'horreur ou encore
Brodeur nombreux ont été des artisans et
des artistes qui ont travaillé sur ce
chef-d'œuvre en utilisant les plus beaux
matériaux
il y a aussi dans cette galerie une
étonnante et rare collection de
traîneaux quand les majestueuses allées
du parc de Versailles étaient recouverte
de neige la course offrait le plaisir
des courses de traîneaux en ce moment
c'est se magnifique traîneau à la sirène
qui est en cours de restauration il a
été créé vers 1740 et ce qui en fait un
trésor c'est notamment ses glacis de
couleur transparent rouge et vert posé
sur de la feuille de roue d'argent qui
ressortit si magnifiquement comme on le
voit une sirène d'une grande beauté hors
de la proue ces traîneaux avaient pour
thème des créatures fantastiques
c'est toute la vie de la cour qui est
évoquée à travers ses objets je vous
propose maintenant de suivre ces hommes
et ces femmes qui ont de l'or dans les
mains
derrière ces incroyables décors le
château de Versailles dissimule une
véritable ruche ou conservateurs et
restaurateurs travaillent ensemble au
service des œuvres
ancien fragile souvent d'une valeur
inestimable le mobilier les objets d'art
demandent un entretien constant une
surveillance irréprochable et parfois
quelques interventions
[Musique]
les équipes du château ont accepté de
nous dévoiler leur prochain grand
chantier la maison de la reine au hameau
c'est ici que Marie-Antoinette vient
accompagner de ses enfants ou de ses
amis respirer le grand air de la liberté
ce hameau a été conçu pour avoir
l'aspect d'un village et en réalité
c'est un château éclaté en plusieurs
morceaux vous avez dans le pavillon
central la salle à manger le salon la
chambre de la reine le boudoir où elle
se repose vous avez derrière le
réchauffement c'est-à-dire la cuisine
les bâtiments domestiques on est là en
fait dans un château qui n'en a pas
l'air
ce château déguisé en village normand
s'inscrit dans la sensibilité du XVIIIe
siècle un courant artistique et social
qui tente à exalter le retour à la
nature et met à la mode la vie des
paysans
il n'est plus question à ce moment-là de
colonne grecque d'avoir une maison qui
ressemble à un temple romain on va faire
un faux amour normand pour inscrire la
pratique architecturale dans les grandes
idées du moment
contrairement aux idées reçues loin
d'être le caprice d'une reine frivole le
hameau est donc dans l'air du temps
l'ennui c'est que ce décor de théâtre
très savant nécessite un entretien
constant nous sommes ici sur un bateau
il faut vivre un pinceau à la main c'est
un bâtiment extraordinairement complexe
et difficile à entretenir
rongé par l'humidité les murs se
lézardent les toitures s'effondre les
dalles se décèlent et les bois
pourrissent
la sécurité n'y étant plus assurée la
maison est fermée au public depuis de
longues années grâce au mécénat de la
maison Dior la maison de la reine va
retrouver peu à peu son apparence
d'origine
il y avait ici à l'époque de
Marie-Antoinette un grand escalier
circulaire qui tournait
autour d'un peuplier j'ai demandé que
l'on puisse faire des fouilles et c'est
fou ils nous ont permis de retrouver
les fondations de l'escalier au 18e
siècle ses fondations vont nous
permettre de refaire l'escalier au plus
près de sa vérité historique
cette ambitieux travaille de
restauration vise à réhabiliter les
décors de théâtre tels que
Marie-Antoinette les a connu mais
surtout à conserver tout ce qui
subsistent encore du crépi vieilli des
lézards en trompe l'oeil des fausses
briques du badigeon tout ce qui faisait
du hameau une ferme de théâtre
tout l'enduit ancien et tout son décor
va être scrupuleusement conservé avec
des techniques de consolidation de
fresques tout simplement c'est les
travaux de sur des églises médiévales
qui nous ont appris des techniques qui
nous permettront ici non seulement de
préserver de dégager et de consolider
tout ce décor d'origine
l'intérieur ne va pas être négligée
aujourd'hui quelques cheminées émergent
d'un désordre de plâtre de revêtement
muraux délavé et d'objets couverts de
rouille humidité lambris pourri tout est
à restaurer
[Musique]
nous arrivons là dans la maison de la
reine à proprement parler nous
traversons la salle à manger et
l'escalier lui-même est un ouvrage très
particulier il est entièrement de la fin
du XVIIIe siècle c'est l'escalier qui a
connu Marie-Antoinette mais dans un
style à la fois rustique et archaïque
avec ses petits balustres tournés se
vide cet escalier très léger
on arrive ici dans la pièce principale
du hameau qui est le salon le salon
implanté au premier étage et là on
change de monde on arrive ici dans une
pièce somptueuse parfaitement lambrisée
avec une magnifique corniche donnant sur
deux côtés de jardin totalement
différent l'un de l'autre
[Musique]
ultime raffinement les fenêtres sont
aussi en trompe l'oeil elles ont deux
menuiseries dont l'une est à vitraux
comme celle des fermes de l'époque pour
un aspect rustique
lorsque la reine était à l'intérieur du
salon ses volets ses fenêtres
extérieures étaient ouvertes
[Musique]
et
on avait depuis ses grands vitrages qui
étaient un luxe au 18e siècle une vision
sur un paysage de rêve autour du hameau
comme un véritable tableau
malheureusement le splendide mobilier
qui ornait ses salons a quasiment
disparu par conséquent pour le
remoblement c'est celui de l'impératrice
Marie-Louise la seconde épouse de
Napoléon qui occupa le hameau 20 ans
après Marie-Antoinette qui a été retenu
nous avons pas mal d'objets datant de
1810 globalement si peut-être les décors
sont un peu plus antiquisants pour
Marie-Louise dans l'ensemble de l'esprit
de Marie-Antoinette est complètement
conservé
[Musique]
les collections du château de Versailles
répartis sur l'ensemble du domaine et
dans les réserves que les conservateurs
vont chercher à réunir se mobilier ainsi
ils ont pu retrouver une série de
fauteuils fabriqués pour l'impératrice
Marie-Louise
[Musique]
ses fauteuils donc on conservé leur
tissu d'origine la plupart du temps les
meubles nous parviennent avec des tissus
qui ont été changés au fil du temps donc
il s'agit de les remettre dans leur état
de 1810 en s'inspirant des inventaires
et donc de choisir les couleurs pour
pouvoir redisposer effectivement le
mobilier dans son état d'origine
commence alors pour les conservateurs un
véritable travail de recherche sur les
couleurs et les matières ou la
sensibilité artistique le dispute à la
vérité historique
alors bien sûr il y a des mouchers qui
proviennent des soyeux ici pour choisir
les couleurs violettes ou les vers de
l'époque Empire vous avez ici un projet
de galons ce sera pour le grand salon
zone du hameau l'intérêt d'avoir tous
ces échantillons c'est aussi si vous
voulez de retrouver l'esprit d'une
époque il est bien entendu qu'il y a des
couleurs encore une fois comme le
ponceau bien spécifique elle est décrite
telle qu'elle dans l'inventaire il faut
que nous la retrouvions à l'identique on
ne peut pas se permettre des fantaisies
décoratives autour de d'une restitution
qui se veut historique pour cela la
conservation fait appel à des artisans
d'art du textile tapissier passementier
soyeux le défi qui se pose est de faire
revivre le meuble tout en restant fidèle
aux sources
ces artisans sont tout à fait
exceptionnels pour beaucoup ce sont les
héritiers des grandes maisons qui des a
travaillé du temps de l'ancien régime
c'est le cas pour les en particulier il
y a pas de secret si vous voulez tout le
monde ne peut pas se taxer de refaire
des pièces de Château c'est vraiment un
travail tout à fait particulier et le
résultat est spectaculaire bon je vais
vous révéler l'une des très belles
pièces de l'ameublement du hameau il
s'agit d'un siège qui va meubler un
petit salon destiné à Marie-Louise
livrée en 1810 pour ce salon
bois d'amarante rechampit en or accotoir
en cuivre une découpe en forme de
gondole particulièrement original
recouverte d'un damas blanc orné de
liseron et palmettes à l'antique
son dessert tout à fait exceptionnel
c'est un mobilier tout à fait original
donc l'une des très belles pièces du
hameau
le salon principal de la maison de la
reine disposait de grands panneaux de
soirée jaune d'une grande rareté nous
avons eu la chance de pouvoir les
découvrir trop fragile pour être exposé
ils sont conservés à l'abri dans les
réserves du château
je vous amène là l'un des panneaux
d'origine datant de 1810 donc à partir
desquels on peut être fait refaite les
reconstitutions qui seront mises donc
dans le salon du hameau maintenant nous
les conservons en fait comme des témoins
historiques si vous voulez du décor du
hameau qui peut être refait à l'infini
puisque nous avons effectivement les
originaux donc c'est devenu extrêmement
précieux c'est extrêmement rare
également les peintures de vos Chelet
sur soirées donc voilà c'est de la
documentation pour nous maintenant mais
de la documentation très précieuse bien
sûr
c'est magnifique panneaux vont donc être
repeints sur la soie à l'identique et
orneront bientôt le salon de la maison
de la reine
nous allons voir que le remublement
d'une pièce va mobiliser des artisans et
des techniciens d'art on compte au
Château Sainte ateliers de restauration
il y a un atelier ébénisterie menuiserie
un atelier d'horreur un atelier et
tapissier pour également les sculptures
pour les arts graphiques tous ces
personnels des ateliers ont une place
très importante dans le dispositif de
restauration et de conservation des
collections du château
ainsi à l'atelier de dorure de
Versailles est arrivé il y a peu une
série de cadres particulièrement
important et destiné à être accrochés
dans l'une des pièces du château
on restaure C4 puisqu'on a retrouvé les
gravures enfin les cadres qui vont avec
les gravures c'est quand même très rare
en fait on a rarement le cadre de
l'oeuvre originale
on me les emmenait comme ça dans cet
état ils sont très très abîmés parce
qu'en fait ils ont dû être mal
entreposés à une époque et ils ont dû
subir et de l'humidité et de la chaleur
en fait donc le bois a beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé et voyez il y a énormément de
petits éléments qui se sont détachés et
il y a beaucoup beaucoup d'éclats en
fait c'est un très très long travail le
travail a consisté à refixer tous les
éléments décollés combler les lacunes et
c'est sous les couches de peinture
posées au 19e siècle que Céline Blondel
a découvert un véritable trésor
vu la bonne surprise de retrouver de
l'or qui a été posée à l'époque de Louis
XV en fait pour la commande royale donc
c'est vraiment très émouvant et c'est
une belle surprise en fait c'est
vraiment une très belle surprise quand
on les voit comme ça d'arriver à un
résultat comme ça
les dorures sur bois ont les mêmes
gestes les mêmes techniques et les mêmes
outils depuis des siècles
[Musique]
dans les petites appartements de Louis
XV le décor est parmi les plus riches et
les plus évocateurs de Versailles
durant son règne des tableaux ornell et
boiseries au-dessus des portes de
l'antichambre
ces œuvres ayant été dispersées à
l'époque révolutionnaire des copies en
grisaille les remplace
les équipes de la conservation ont pu
retrouver certains de ces tableaux dont
l'un est actuellement en restauration sa
taille a été considérablement réduite
après avoir quitté Versailles pour le
remettre à sa dimension d'origine les
restaurateurs ont agrandi le châssis et
remplacer les parties manquantes c'est
une œuvre qu'il faut restituer comme un
décor de 17e siècle et à ce moment-là ça
justifie complètement la création des
agrandissements selon d'ailleurs une
tradition propre au château de
Versailles ce que c'est quelque chose
qui s'est fait pendant 200 ans la
restauration elle est toujours entre ces
deux pôles le pôle historique est le
polystique et très souvent en fonction
du but de cette restauration on est
plutôt dans l'histoire l'archéologie ou
plutôt dans l'esthétique
ce qui doit ressortir c'est la scène
centrale le reste c'est du décor et dans
cette restauration rien n'est définitif
toutes les interventions sont absolument
réversibles
[Musique]
deux des quatre tableaux qui sont
revenus à Versailles ont déjà été
restaurés ils vont retrouver sous nos
yeux leur place d'origine dans
l'antichambre des chiens
la restitution du décor du tableau n'est
pas visible au premier coup d'oeil mais
le visiteur attentif pourra l'apercevoir
en voilà la ligne qui est ici
la marque qui est l'original
après 218 années d'absence les tableaux
vont être replacés dans les boiseries si
vous avez en quelque sorte l'équivalent
du rameublement on peut remettre en
place des tableaux qui ont été présentés
jusqu'à 97 1797 1798 dans cette pièce
pour faire revenir ces tableaux il a
fallu quatre longues années de
négociation avec d'autres établissements
c'était des collections
achetées par Louis XIV
présenté au château de Versailles
envoyer au musée central des arts le
musée du Louvre puis déposé dans des
musées de province de Dole de
Carcassonne de Montpellier et de Rennes
petit à petit l'anti-chambre des chiens
retrouve son aspect d'origine mais il
manque encore deux œuvres qui sont hélas
toujours au musée du Louvre
[Musique]
s'il est un endroit dans le château qui
est la parfaite synthèse de ce travail
incroyable de restauration et
demeublement c'est le salon de
l'abondance
l'atmosphère qui régnait dans le grand
appartement du roi au temps de Louis XIV
y a été restitué Louis XIV est un très
grand collectionneur passionné par là il
avait des collections de peinture il
avait des collections de sculptures il
avait des collections de bronze il avait
des collections de d'antiques pour être
souverain il faut être versé vers
l'Antiquité qui est la référence
quelques-uns de ces chefs dont bon
nombre ont disparu sont représentés sur
la voûte les stucs les plombs les
menuiseries mais aussi le décor peint on
fait l'objet d'une grande campagne de
restauration
[Musique]
le salon entièrement remodelé et la
quintessence du siècle qui consacre le
génie du grand ébéniste André
charleboule il faut voir en boule aussi
bien un ébéniste qu'un bronzier avec les
têtes de femmes ailées et on voit
l'originalité qui est en fait le souffle
baroque la magnificence baroque de
l'époque en 1708 pour le roi Louis XIV
[Musique]
le travail de la conservation n'est pas
seulement de remodeler ou de restaurer
mais aussi de conserver gérer et
présenter les collections au public je
me trouve ici au premier étage de l'aile
nord du château au cœur du Musée
national de Versailles au 18e siècle ces
espaces étaient occupés par des
appartements des princes du sang on peut
y voir aujourd'hui des oeuvres dont
l'accrochage attouche touche était en
vogue à l'époque de Louis-Philippe qui a
détruit ses appartements pour laisser
place à une partie du musée de
l'Histoire de France c'est ça le retrace
le siècle de Louis XIV à travers une
galerie de peinture avec cette grande
toile d'Henri Testelin il s'agissait de
célébrer les grands événements du règne
ainsi que les grandes réalisations la
création de l'Académie des Sciences en
1666 s'intègre dans ce grand projet de
la monarchie absolue visant à placer
l'ensemble de la vie culturelle sous la
tutelle du roi
ces collections sont au cœur des
préoccupations de l'équipe de Béatrix
soul de nombreux projets sont en cours
ici à Versailles afin de rendre ses
chefs les plus accessibles possible
[Musique]
Versailles et résidences royales mais
elle est aussi un grand musée à la fois
par sa taille et par ses collections des
collections qui sont très importantes en
nombre et aussi et surtout c'est moins
connus d'une grande diversité ça veut
dire que il y a tout le travail pour les
inventoriers
les collections du château sont classées
dans une base de données alimentées par
les conservateurs tous les 10 ans chacun
des objets d'art est passé à la loupe
toutes les indications portées au cours
des siècles sont relevés
estompe de l'artisan étiquette numéro
d'inventaire permettent de retracer le
parcours de l'objet depuis sa commande
jusqu'à nos jours
cette base de données est donc
nécessaire au travail de remublement du
château mais elle va encore plus loin
elle permet de faire un état sanitaire
de l'objet à un instant T j'ai noté donc
un trou d'envol qui est ici et donc
présentiel d'un insecte xylophage donc
objet potentiellement à surveillé à
cause de cela également il y a en façade
la ceinture sur le côté et dans d'autres
endroits il y a des chocs des petits
enfoncements je vais les noter dans la
base informatisée je vais les
photographier également et tous ces
éléments permettront de connaître
exactement l'état physique de l'objet et
si jamais par malheur la fissure que
vous avez là où là doit s'élargir la
photo permettra de constater qu'il y a
une évolution
[Musique]
la diversité des oeuvres est-elle qu’il
existe sur le domaine de Versailles des
lieux méconnus du public mais qui recèle
pourtant un très grand nombre d'oeuvres
d'art le projet de l'équipe et de
valoriser ses chefs et de permettre au
plus grand nombre de les admirer ainsi
la petite écurie construite par Jules
Ardoin Mansart abrite les sculptures
originales de la statuaire des jardins
de Versailles le plus bel exemple de ce
sculpture et la grande commande un
ensemble de 24 statues commandées par le
roi Louis XIV en 1674 au plus grands
artistes de son temps
c'est un ensemble de 24 allégories qui
symbolise l'influence du soleil sur le
monde sachant que le soleil évidemment
c'est l'emblème de Louis XIV donc c'est
un hommage indirect à Louis XIV lui-même
et ici c'est l'heure du soir qui est
représenté sous la forme de cette Diane
chasseresse accompagnée de son lévrier
l'oeuvre est sublime parce que on a une
attitude presque dansante très dynamique
en tout cas et ensuite le détail aussi
est extrêmement soigné l'élégance aussi
de la chevelure du diadème et l'art de
Desjardins justement est perceptible
dans toute cette minutie ce souci du
détail
toutes ces sculptures en marbre de
cararh exposés en extérieur depuis 300
ans ont subi les intempéries et l'usure
naturelle du temps ainsi l'allégorie du
soir l'ont en présenté sur le parterre
d'eau s'est considérablement détérioré
on peut le voir à l’œil nu en se
rapprochant de l'oeuvre on a une partie
donc qui est où l'épiderme d'origine est
préservée ce sont les parties abritées
ici le marbre est lisse et puis en
revanche ici le marbre est très abîmé on
voit la structure cristalline du marbre
avec les petits grains qui se
déchaussent au toucher c'est comme du
papier de verre alors que ici on est sur
une surface lisse qui a gardé donc son
aspect d'origine depuis 2008 une grande
campagne vise à remplacer les statues
des jardins par des copies et à mettre
les originaux à l'abri pour mieux la
préserver la magnifique statue d'Achille
askiros est en cours de moulage elle est
recouverte d'une gang d'élastomère qui
épouse la forme originale et qui ensuite
formera le moule
dans le creux du moule que l'on va
couler le matériau pour la copie qui
sera parfaitement fidèle à l'original
jusque dans ses altérations
il ne s'agit pas de reconstituer une
oeuvre selon un état illusoire qui
n'existe plus mais de rester fidèle à
l'oeuvre au moment où on la met à l'abri
à l'intérieur du château donc la lèvre
est enveloppée de cet élastomère quand
cet élastomère sera sec on l'enrobera
encore d'un moule de plâtre et d'une
chape et c'est après donc aura lieu le
démoulage et ainsi le moule sera
constitué
une fois prête la copie sera alors
exposée dans les jardins mais les
visiteurs pourront en admirer l'original
qui sera prochainement présenté sur le
domaine
[Musique]
une autre façon de montrer les
collections ce sont les expositions qui
peuvent être organisées en les murs en
partenariat avec d'autres musées ou dans
le cadre même du château ainsi nous
avons pu assister au montage d'une
grande exposition autour de la mort de
Louis XIV
Béatrice Saul a fait appel à l'italien
pierre Luigi Pizzi metteur en scène
d'opéra spécialiste du baroque pour
illustrer le grand spectacle donné en
ces occasions les deux concurrents le
régent et le duc du Maine qui se
retrouvent ensemble voilà donc là c'est
pour voir à quelle hauteur on va le
mettre
peut-être
d'être haut voilà donc
c'est bien là c'est bien là c'est bien
le premier septembre 1715 Louis XIV
s'est éteint
cette exposition sur les rites
funéraires du pouvoir une première en
France dévoile à quel point les
cérémonies funèbres sont un moyen de
montrer la puissance de la monarchie
française
la reconstitution de ce que l'on appelle
un cénotaphe accueille les visiteurs
cette exposition s'ouvre sur un grand
effet qui est la restitution à grandeur
exacte de ce qui avait pu être installé
dans la basilique de Saint-Denis pour
abriter et honorer le corps de Louis XIV
avant qu'il y ait le grand service
funèbre du 23 octobre
celui-ci est le cénotaphe provisoire
donc là on peut donner l'impression de
ce que les temporaires pouvaient
ressentir en face de ça
ce cénotaphe réalisé à l'époque en
papier mâché dans la tente du monument
définitif pour les funérailles n'a bien
entendu pas été sauvegardé
donc on a tout perdu et nous sommes
partis d'une d'une gravure qui nous a
donné au moins l'idée et la dimension
[Musique]
la maquette du monument funéraire de
cérémonie a été réalisé à un cinquième
de sa grandeur réelle puisqu'il mesurait
à l'époque 32 mètres de haut un monument
incomparable de luxe le roi a vécu toute
sa vie en représentation oui il continue
il est né à représentation donc
son peuple pour donner une image d'une
grandeur qui a accompagné toute sa vie
à côté d'oeuvres venues du monde entier
l'exposition permet aux équipes de
Versailles de présenter de nombreux
documents tableau ou objets puisés dans
les collections ou non exposées
d'ordinaire
au château le prochain grand défi c'est
le redéploiement des collections du
musée de l'Histoire de France dans les
galeries historiques du château
ce musée créé par Louis-Philippe en 1837
rassemble des chefs-d'œuvre accumulés
par ces prédécesseurs et d'autres
commander sous son règne il raconte une
histoire de France continue depuis
Clovis jusqu'en 1830 c'est l'album de la
France dans le musée Louis-Philippe ce
sont les moments heureux de la France
qui sont représentés et on n'a pas les
défaites on n'a pas les événements les
plus tragiques de notre histoire nous
avons la chance d'avoir cette collection
qui est un vrai trésor c'est à dire nous
sommes le seul pays au monde qui
conserve toute son histoire nationale
dans un même lieu
œuvre sont des icônes des images qui
sont dans toutes les têtes mais dont on
imagine pas qu'elle se trouve ici à
Versailles
comme le célèbre tableau de David qui
peint La Traversée des Alpes par l'armée
française en 1800 et représente
Bonaparte en héros menons ses troupes
sur un cheval fougueux
alors ce qui est amusant c'est qu'en
fait on sait qu'il a franchi les Alpes
sur le dos d'un mulet comme il le
pouvait parce qu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment d'autres moyens de franchir
se relief particulièrement accidenté
très enneigée à cette fin du printemps
c'est une image complètement fabriquée
c'est une image de propagande on peut
vraiment dire ça aujourd'hui ou de
communication si on préfère le mot
Napoléon portrait après portrait
construit sa légende
ou des portraits d'hommes célèbres des
politiques des écrivains
des poètes c'est le portrait le plus
célèbre de Victor Hugo probablement
parce que c'était le portrait qui le
représente et le bon vieillard le grand
vieillard en fait que qu'on montre comme
modèle aux enfants des écoles et c'est
un portrait qui a été reproduit dans
tous les ouvrages de l'histoire et de
littérature depuis qu'il a été peint et
présenté au Salon
l'idée des équipes est d'inscrire
ses que dans un projet pédagogique
nous voulons absolument faire comprendre
que ces œuvres ne sont pas de strict
représentation de la réalité mais
vraiment des œuvres de réécriture on
recompose l'histoire on l'a réécrit dans
le sens qui favorable pour l'événement
pour la France pour le personnage
représenté
le projet des équipes de valoriser une
présentation de ces collections d'un
autre siècle avec les moyens
d'aujourd'hui et de mettre en avant les
hommes et les femmes qui ont fait notre
histoire
[Musique]
Versailles nous oblige on se sent
constamment tributaire de ce passé il
faut être à la hauteur de se passer
c'est-à-dire le respecter et encore une
fois le faire vivre le transmettre et
donc il s'agit d'ouvrir au maximum ce
lieu pour en montrer toutes les
richesses tous les trésors tous les
chefs
[Musique]
Versailles est une fée riz somptueuse et
théâtrale c'est aussi une démonstration
de gloire et de puissance exalté jusqu'à
la démesure par l'art l'éclat et la
magnificence
la Révolution française et les
vicissitudes du temps ont brutalement
ôté son lustre à ce palais démesuré
vider délaisser abandonner il a manqué
de peu d’être détruit
conscient de sa valeur inestimable
quelques hommes et femmes se sont donnés
pour mission de le faire renaître et le
château de Versailles fut sauvé il
représente aujourd'hui 350 ans après la
pose de sa première pierre l'emblème de
la France à travers le monde
grâce au travail passionné des équipes
qui hier comme aujourd'hui s'acharne à
le préserver le restaurer le magnifique
il recouvre sa beauté et toute sa
faculté à nous fasciner
[Musique]
comme nous l'avons vu le château de
Versailles suscite de véritables
passions parmi ceux qui au quotidien
veille sur tous ces trésors il fait
aussi rêver ses visiteurs des écoliers
qui le découvrent au chef d'État qui
l’impressionne s'il réunit en a même
lieu les chefs-d'œuvre des plus grands
artistes de notre histoire il en est
aussi le reflet le plus brillant
résidence royale musée de l'Histoire de
France le château de Versailles est une
œuvre d'art totale voilà j'espère vous
avoir fait découvrir Versailles
différemment et vous avoir donné envie
de venir admirer tous ces chefs quant à
moi je vous retrouve très bientôt pour
découvrir de nouveaux trésors
[Musique]